the movie is set in the year 250 when
the earth is completely covered by water
the polar ice caps have melted and sea
levels have risen over 25 ft with people
living on the water the world is now
adapting to the new ways of living
people live on boats and have colonies
that are made on ships the entirety of
human civilization has forgotten about
living on land to the point that the
idea is now a myth the movie starts with
a man Mariner who lives on this Earth as
a loner he has his own boat made from
the scavenged trash in the ocean called
traran and recycles his urine as
drinking water he spends his days
collecting artifacts and food from the
bottom of the ocean one day while he is
out in the ocean doing his regular
chores a stranger approaches him the
stranger first comes with a friendly
face after a while he finds out that his
limes a rare fruit are stolen just then
another boat with smokers the pirates of
the new world come to steal scavenged
things from Mariner then during the
chaos he finds out that the stranger is
the one who stole his limes seeing this
Mariner gets Furious and tries to get
him this makes him extremely Furious and
he sails towards that stranger's boat
even though his boat looks like it's
made out of trash the boat is extremely
fast he then sails right over the
drifter's small boat and destroys it
leaving him for the smokers after that
he sets out to sail towards Adel a
colony that he had heard would make
trades with him at first he is not
allowed to enter when shown that he has
some good dirt which is very valuable
these days like a commodity his entry
looks legit and then is given permission
to enter when he enters he realizes that
the situation there is worse than it is
out there people there have no food and
are living in extreme poverty he then
meets a guy who gives him 2 hours to
finish everything is here for he goes to
the market and tries to sell some dirt
in exchange for some currency called
chits he finds one Merchant willing to
give him a huge chunk of money Niner
asks the merchant to double the money
during that time a guy named nor is
asking around about a girl with a tattoo
that is a map of a dry land after a
while he spots that girl who is going by
the name Inola she is being taken care
of by Helen who is a local bid meanwhile
Mariner spends his chips on a tomato
plant and some shelves for his boat
while he is returning to his boat a
family approaches him to impregnate
their daughter because inbreeding within
the colony was causing huge
complications in children and they
didn't want that for their daughter but
marinina refuses them weirded about the
fact that a man is rejecting a woman the
people of adle take him into custody
during that one of the people discovers
that he is a mutant with gills and
webbed feet unfortunately the people of
Adel are horrified by the mutation and
decide to cage him they attack him and
he is imprisoned until further notice he
is caged over at the Docks the Mariner
notices some of the young people
scavening and stealing some of Tran's
belongings as they leave the adle
secretly Helen starts talking with her
investor buddy Gregor on the other side
who is also looking for dry land she
tells him that anola might be in danger
and that all three of them should leave
that place as soon as possible Gregor
tells her that they can't do so because
no one can read the map tattooed on her
back the girl looks mysterious and
always draws weird pictures and symbols
that she does not recognize later Inola
tells them that Mariner might be able to
read the tattoo and that Gregor should
ask him at night Gregor carefully
approaches Mariner he starts asking him
a bunch of questions about his mutation
he also asks him about dry land and
everything suddenly someone comes and
their conversation ends with Gregor
leaving in the morning everyone
surrounds Mariner and a decision is made
to drown him in a pit of organic sludge
while in the process of recycling him at
the same time time and AD all's lookout
spots a large army of smokers led by
Deacon coming to their settlement in
search of anola then when the locals
begin to fear an attack the execution of
the Mariner is postponed Helen tries to
flee with anola on a hot air balloon
that Gregor made as the smoker's attack
but the balloon is unintentionally
released too soon leaving Helen and
Enola behind amidst all this Mariner's
cage is knocked and he is slowly
drowning in the pit but the two girls
decide to save him hoping that in return
he would also save them Helen goes to
save him giving him the ultimatum that
she'll do so only if he agrees to take
both of them with him Mariner agrees
Mariner then goes to his ship the girls
open the gates of adle as an escape
route meanwhile Deacon interrupts their
escape Mariner quickly fights them off
and all of them Escape safely meanwhile
Deacon finds out that anola escaped with
the help of Mariner then sets his crew
out to get her back at the Mariner's
boat Helen asks him about his knowledge
of dry land he tells her that he does
and they have a better chance of getting
there if they throw Inola overboard due
to limited supplies Helen instantly
rejects the idea and tries to change his
mind by offering herself to her but to
her dismay he refuses her she then grabs
a gun and threatens him but Mariner
knocks her out at that time Deacon and
his Smoker's Base is located at a giant
oil tanker inside Deacon tries to get
his doctor to make him a prosthetic eye
after the failure to do so he instead
gets a patch for his eye then upon
inspecting he realizes the ship's oil is
low and asks his minions to quickly go
look out for her via the airplane on the
boat when anola starts drawing her
symbols on the ship Mariner gets Furious
he throws her overboard and Helen
screams she yells that she cannot swim
so she goes to get her Mariner changes
his mind about leaving them and decides
to save them suddenly the plane sent out
by Deacon finds them Mariner goes down
to prepare a weapon but fearful Helen
panics and starts shooting to make the
situation worse the plane instead starts
circling the plane with a metal rope
this causes serious damage to the plane
with efforts to cut that rope he climbs
on it but the airplane pilot shoots at
First Mariner plunges into the ocean and
the pilot escapes furious with what just
happened Mariner decided to cut both of
the girls hair as a punishment he tells
them to never touch anything on the boat
ever again he also asks Inola to never
draw on the boat again back at the
Smoker's Den the pilot tells Deacon
about the girl's whereabouts he then
tells them to intercept the three on the
way on the other side Mariner comes
across a Drifter he tells them that he
has a very important paper that might
have Clues on the dry land Mariner tells
tells him that he doesn't have anything
he can trade with The Drifter simply
asks for half an hour with Helen Mariner
agrees The Drifter along with Helen who
protested is locked below the deck upon
finding that the papers are worthless he
quickly goes to save Helen from the man
The Drifter gets Furious and tries to
kill him fight happens but Mariner kills
him and throws him off the boat all
three of them are now desperate for food
so he shows the girls how he hunts for
food he goes into the water with his gun
he acts like a bait in the ocean and to
his credit a mutated shark Tri to
swallow him instead he kills that shark
first and all of them have a feast the
next morning Mariner teaches Inola how
to swim Helen is happy with the bonding
of the two after a few days the trio is
once again ambushed by the smoker from
underwater a mariner realizes the Ambush
and turns his boat to escape they barely
manage to escape even after the Deacon
opens fire with his rifle wounding the
Mariner he asks Helen if she knows
anything about why they are being
ambushed again and again Helen tells him
that she is the girl with a tattoo of a
m m to the dry land he tells her that
it's all a myth and has never come
remotely close to a dry land listening
to it Helen gets angry in an effort to
convince her he takes her underneath in
a homemade diving bell Mariner goes
without it because he has gills and he
can swim they go deep down into the
submerged City when they return back
they realize that smokers have come
again they threaten to kill anola if
they do not hand her over immediately
Enola who is hiding resurfaces upon
hearing the firing of guns thinking her
friends are in danger Enola gets caught
The Smokers upon the Deacon's order
start trying to kill the other two but
two of them dive into the ocean he
kisses her so that he can breathe for
the both of them Upon returning they
find that anola along with the smokers
are now gone Mariner tells Helen how
much is feels lonely and Helen kisses
him both of them share intimate moments
together the next morning he starts
looking at Ana's drawing and starts
making connections with the images in
the National Geographic collections when
he looks at the various objects such as
trees and other land objects he thinks
that all this talk about dry land might
actually be true after a while Gregor
finds them in a hot air balloon he takes
them towards the makeshift atle with
survivors they discuss the various ways
to get to the dry land only to discover
that their efforts are useless without
anola some argue that rescuing her is
much more of a danger Mariner goes off
to save her alone he goes off on a boat
alone after reaching the Smoker's Den he
starts killing anyone who gets in the
way Mariner confronts the Deacon and
holds out a flare threatening to ignite
the oil reserves and the tanker unless
he returns in Noah Deacon thinking that
it's a bluff doesn't believe it but
Mariner drops the flare into the oil
reserve of the ship and the ship
explodes into flames amidst everything
Deacon takes anola and tries to fly with
her on the plane but Mariner stops them
by anchoring the plane with a metal wire
he rescues her and both of them Embrace
each other meanwhile Gregor with his hot
air balloon shows up they immediately
let down a rope for the Mariner to
escape as he brings anola to Helen but
to everyone's surprise Deacon starts
climbing that rope too to Mariner kicks
and throws him into the water Deacon
then finds a jet ski and shoots at the
hot air balloon it disbalances the
balloon and an Ola falls into the ocean
while Deacon is trying to get her
Mariner ties himself with a cord and
Bungie jumps into the ocean to get her
right after he gets her the three jet
skis with Deacon and his men collide
with one another they die due to the
explosion later on Gregor manages to
identify the tattoo on in noa's back as
the coordinates and the reverse
directions after a few days of flying
they discover the dry land upon
following the coordinates filled with
vegetation and sand and everything
they've never seen before the entire
group is fascinated by the discovery
they go inside the small Hut there and
find skeletons of people they discover
that the remains are of enola's parents
they realize that maybe the girl was
sent out with the hopes that she would
bring more people to the dry land the
people give her parents a proper burial
everyone in the dry land seems to be
having fun but Mariner feels out of
place the dry land feels awkward and
like he doesn't really belong there he
decides to leave and go out into the
ocean where he feels at home Enola tells
him that maybe he will adapt but he
feels that the ocean is his calling
everyone respects his decision and he
starts building a wooden boat Helen and
Enola bid him farewell Mariner promises
to tell others about the dry land the
movie ends with Helen and Enola climbing
to the highest hill to watch him Sail
Away only to discover that they are
standing on top of Mount Everest